President Trump is personally advocating
for an American rapper facing legal
trouble in Sweden but Sweden's Prime
Minister says the president cannot
influence how ASAP rocky is treated in
an assault case there now video captured
the rapper and a fight in Stockholm last
month and he was taken into custody days
later mola Lengai reports on why ASAP
rocky says he is a victim here I have
been called by so many people asking me
to help a rocky
president Trump is now working with
Swedish authorities to demand ASAP
Rocky's release and credited the first
lady with bringing his case to light we
working with State Department and we we
hope to get him home soon video from
June 30th shows ASAP rocky and three
others confronted by two men on a
stockholm street in one tense moment one
of the men tries to punch and throws
headphones at Rocky's bodyguard we don't
want to fight leading rocky and others
to try to apparently de-escalate the
situation you can hear them ask the two
men to leave them alone several times
minutes later a second video appears to
show the rapper and his friends
violently throw one of the men to the
ground punching and kicking him
repeatedly they were arrested for
assault Kanye and Kim kardashian-west
are among a chorus of celebrities
calling for Rocky's release one hip-hop
star Tyler the Creator tweeted that he'd
boycott Sweden forever lawmakers are
also stepping in he was being taunted in
her ass
leading the charge is congressman
Adriano Espeon who represents Rocky's
district in New York City anyone that
sees the video understands that these
these young men were pushed to a corner
and they are in fact the victims that
was more lengthy four questions in this
story Sweden not typically on the wrong
side of an incarceration story you think
of them as a neutral party yeah people
go but there did seem to be some
provocation that video from what we
could see I'm very curious about how
many ASAP rocky songs the president has
on his plan seems funny to even hear him
say ASAP Rocky it's not so much
everything see all the tweets calling
for the president to look into this and
then he claims he was getting phone
calls about it
his idea yeah to be continued yeah and
again that was mullet lengthy for us
reporting more thank you very much